[Musique]
la vallée du mois avait surnommée la
vallée de la mort à cause de son climat
aride
un paysage dramatique qui nous rappelle
des films iconique bagdad café casino ou
encore les oiseaux
il ya des éclairs mais pas de pluie le
mercure indique en moyenne 40 degrés
au loin un mirage un oasis et non ce
sont des milliers de panneaux solaires
qui nous rappelle qu'on est bien au 21e
siècle et que la planète a besoin
d'autre solution pour poursuivre sa
cadence
le plus préoccupant ici c'est le lac mid
principale source d'eau dans la région
tout près de las vegas en plein coeur du
nevada ce lac artificiel créé par le
barrage hoover détonne avec le paysage
désertique il disparaît presque sous nos
yeux à cause de la sécheresse
je suis inquiet dit-il devrions nous
quitter vegas est ce qu'il va nous
manquer mais
personne n'y croit moi je suis pris pour
plus de neige
ceci n'est même plus une rampe de mise à
l'eau pour les bêtes odyssée filles et à
fait
car jadis il y avait huit marina il ne
reste plus que deux
[Musique]
en plein désert une communauté de
plaisanciers s'étaient formées l'endroit
est presque vide
susan boyle
nous avons tous des bateaux dit il mon
peu plus les mettre à l'eau car il n'y a
plus de rampe il n'en reste qu'une et
les files d'attentes sont de 4 à 5
heures la fin de semaine
le liquid est le plus grand réservoir
d'eau aux etats unis ils approvisionnent
en eau et en électricité le nevada
l'arizona la californie
il est à son niveau le plus bas est pour
beaucoup c'est un point de non retour
cet été le niveau baisser de 30 cm par
semaine dit elle c'était choquant x
jocelyne et belle sillonnent de la ddt
depuis une vingtaine d'années le niveau
de l'eau a baissé de près de 50 mètres
comme en témoigne ce rocher la partie
blanche était submergé il y a vingt ans
aujourd'hui le lac à une profondeur d'à
peine plus de 300 mètres ce qui pourrait
être inquiétant
et avec la baisse du niveau de l'eau le
lac a révélé ses secrets les plus
sordides des cadavres ont refait surface
des corps retrouvés dans l'eau qui ont
la signature de la mafia de l'époque
nous dit on car ils contrôlaient les
casinos plusieurs enquêtes sont en cours
- depuis moins de neige qui fond pour
alimenter le fleuve du colorado qui
prend sa source dans les rocheuses et
qui alimente le barrage hoover
lorsque le niveau de l'eau va atteindre
300 mètres dit elle le barrage ne pourra
plus généré d'électricité
40 millions de personnes dans cet état
dépend de ce fleuve en électricité en
eau
est un fermier de l'arizona juste à la
frontière du nevada
[Musique]
80% de l'eau puisée dans le fleuve est
utilisé par les fermiers de ce tour les
yeux
c'est une méga sécheresse dit il je n'ai
jamais vu ça en 45 ans le fleuve un
débit très faible
je suis très inquiet dit-il c'est toute
ma vie en 2023 et vont couper 21 % de
notre approvisionnement en eau s'il n'y
a pas de compensation les fermes vont
s'assécher et c'est notre gagne pain
il cultive entre autres la luzerne les
plus de la moitié de ses terres sont en
jachère
[Musique]
nous vivons dans le désert il faut agir
en conséquence ou d'idées munch
porte-parole de l' agence de
conservation de l'eau au nevada à
wolsong ont lieu chaque utilisateur du
fleuve devra prendre des décisions
difficiles douloureuse pour l'avenir
et l'état prend ses moyens dès 6 heures
du matin la police de l'eau parcours le
sud du nevada pour s'assurer qu'il n'y
ait pas de gaspillage
interdiction d'arroser entre 11h et 19h
et pas plus de trois jours par semaine
et jamais le dimanche et surtout
s'assurer que l'eau ne coule pas
impunément dans la rue
la première amende et de 80 dollars
dit-il et si ce n'est pas corrigé on
double l'amande et ainsi de suite
toute l'eau utilisée à l'intérieur des
maisons et récupérés et recyclés et puis
on encourage la population à se
débarrasser de ces pelouse
atchoum ghost world race on s'est
débarrassé de près de 20 kilomètres
carrés de pelouse dit il et avons
économisé 617 milliards de litres d'eau
nous avons encore beaucoup de gazon dit
elle il va falloir enlever tout ça d'ici
le nevada agi en bon élève dans la
région à cause des efforts depuis 20 ans
pour la conservation de l'eau malgré
tout dès janvier 2023 l'état devra
réduire sa consommation d'eau de 8%
l'arizona de 21% et le mexique 2 7% la
californie est épargné pour le moment ce
qui crée des tensions
la californie ne doit pas réduire son
approvisionnement dit il pour toi ils
reçoivent beaucoup d'eau vers le one
world tout le monde doit être vigilant
sinon on court à notre perte il n'y aura
plus d'électricité plus d'eau imaginez
la ville de phoenix sans électricité
phoenix los angeles las vegas sans
électricité sans eau tout ceci semble
inimaginable
les casinos en plein désert carbure
toujours à l'air climatisé
on vit au rythme des machines dans des
tours réfrigérée avec le mirage d'une
vie meilleure comme si la réalité
extérieure n'était finalement qu'un
mauvais cauchemar à oublier
[Musique]